[Musique]
Sandrine Gomez bonjour Sandrine
de presse déjà nous partons pour la
Chine avec le 20e congrès du Parti
communiste il s'ouvre dimanche prochain
oui ce congrès 20e congrès du Parti
communiste chinois il est bien sûr à la
une de la presse chinoise on va
d'ailleurs regarder la une du China
délit ce matin ils mettent en avant une
consultation présentée comme inédite de
personnalité non membres du Parti
communiste chinois en vue de la
rédaction du rapport du 20e congrès
national un document programme nous dit
si ce quotidien pour l'édification je
cite intégral d'un pays socialiste
moderne et pour avancer filmer vers
l'objectif du deuxième centenaire on
assure ici que les opinions qui ont été
exprimées seront bien prises en compte
voilà donc le semblant de démocratie
dont veut se parer ce 20e congrès qui
doit entériner un troisième mandat de
Sea Jinping un grand rendez-vous du
Parti communiste chinois qui est bien
sûr scruté par la presse international
le journal français l'opinion regardait
souligne que ce congrès c'est l'occasion
pour site jinking de rester au pouvoir
et de s'assurer que la Chine
n'empruntera pas la voix de l'URSS alors
ici on rappelle qu'en septembre dernier
depuis son chef de la police ont été
condamnés à perpétuité ils ont été
accusés de former une clique politique
c'est la plus grande purge du système de
sécurité qui est intervenu depuis que si
Jinping a lancé sa vaste campagne de
lutte contre la corruption et tout cela
bien sûr ne doit pas faire oublier
quelque chose qui est assez inédit et
que l'on retrouve ce matin dans les unes
dans les dans les colonnes du gardianne
regardez ce titre des manifestations
dans la rue contre sea Jinping et le
confinement ont éclaté à Pékin avant ce
congrès crucial c'était ce jeudi
figurez-vous Philomé que quelques
clichés de rares vidéos ont fuité dans
les réseaux sociaux on y voit des gens
avec des pancartes sc
on veut de la nourriture pas des tests
on veut du respect le respect des gens
et pas des mensonges nous voulons des
réformes pas une révolution culturelle
une manifestation donc très rare la
contestation en Chine avant un tel
événement la Chine donc à l'aube du 20e
congote du Parti communiste tout à fait
autre chose la une maintenant
ce vendredi du Figaro nous sommes deux
ans après la mort de Samuel Paty oui la
date de l'assassinat en réalité c'est
plutôt ce dimanche date de la
décapitation de ce professeur
d'histoire-géographie pour un cours sur
la liberté d'expression les
établissements sont libres d'organiser
des hommages donc ce vendredi ou lundi
l'occasion d'un constat regarder pour à
la ligne du Figaro deux ans après
l'école est toujours sous menace
islamiste les enseignants continuent
d'être la cible de provocation ou de
menaces de mort le constat inspire ici
ce titre de
la honte le collège du bois d'aulne à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine ne portera
finalement pas le nom de Samuel Paty
l'idée a finalement été abandonnée
personne ne veut prendre cette
initiative à l'heure où les jeunes
iraniennes écrit Yves réars se font
trouer la peau pour mettre à bas leur
voile et recouvrer la liberté bien le
pays de la laïcité tremble encore devant
les ennemis de la République que sont
les gardiens de la charia en jeu cite et
leurs exécutants il pose ici cette
question à quoi aura servi la mort de
Samuel Patty dans les établissements
scolaires les chefs d'établissement se
sentent Sandrine aussi démuni face à
l'augmentation des atteintes à la
laïcité on se musiciens sur les derniers
chiffres communiqués hier par
l'Éducation nationale 313 signalement
dont 54 relatifs à des ports de signes
et de tenue religieuses alors résultat à
la ligne de la Croix les chefs
d'établissement veulent des règles qui
soient claires sur la laïcité beaucoup
réclame d'ailleurs l'inscription dans la
loi comme pour le voile de
l'interdiction des abayas cette fois
dont les signalements ont
considérablement augmenté ces derniers
temps dans les établissements les abayas
c'est ce vêtement féminin qui recouvre
qui se porte au-dessus des autres
vêtements notamment dans les pays
musulmans épreuves que beaucoup ont déjà
oublié Samuel Paty regardez cet article
du Parisien qui est assez sidérant ce
titre Samuel Paty il est au PSG voilà
l'une des réponses d'un jeune lycéen de
banlieue il a 19 ans et il a donc été
interrogé par le journaliste qui écrit
le l'article du Parisien dans la presse
française également après les
raffineries les mouvements de grève qui
s'étendent oui alors les grèves elle
s'étendent car
l'essence et bien ça fait tâche d'huile
voilà le titre de libération ce matin en
une le journal qui est graine ici et
bien les nouveaux secteurs qui rentrent
dans le bal transport énergie industrie
chimie automobile partout dans la foule
et raffineries on annonce des débrayages
contre la re pour la revalorisation des
salaires et contre et pour la défense
également du droit de grève après donc
l'annonce des réquisitions par le
gouvernement des salariés des
raffineries emmenés par la CGT cette
fois il y a solidaire F- il avait fait
ce qui ont donc acté cette grande
journée de mobilisation mardi prochain
donc c'est un mouvement qui ceux qui se
durcit et la faute à qui alors pour la
libération la faute est bien plutôt au
gouvernement qui a sorti les muscles
avec cet ordre de réquisition et qui
témoigne selon le journal d'un travail
d'amateur d'une erreur d'amateurs un
manque de lucidité
sur ses propres forces son point ici
dans l'édito une majorité relative à
l'Assemblée élément de fragilisation
quand il s'agit d'engager Philomène une
épreuve de force plus indulgent en
revanche le journal Les Échos observe
que le gouvernement a simplement à
seulement tardé à prendre conscience de
ce qui se passait pour le journal
économique la responsabilité de la CGT
est évidente avec 150 salariés qui
bloquent tout le pays mais celle de
Total énergie également la
responsabilité totale est engagée ici on
pointe un dialogue social médiocre et
des maladresses qui conduisent à faire
oublier le joli coup de com avec la
diminution on le sait en de 20 centimes
au litre à la pompe de carburant dans
les stations de Total énergie dont la
dernière question où en est justement le
prix à la pompe
qui s'envole le Parisien a
identifié la station la plus chère de
France et dans le 7e arrondissement de
la capitale c'est une station trottoir
de dépannage prix affiché de 9 vite pour
le sans plomb 2 99 pour le gasoil record
absolu mais ici aussi on fait la queue
et on est bien content de pouvoir faire
le plein film merci beaucoup Sandrine
Gomez c'était la revue de presse